[Music]
foreign
the tongue has no bones but bones it
crushes
[Music]
wine and children speak the truth
a society grows great when old men plant
trees whose shade they know they shall
never sit in
win by persuasion not by force
[Music]
one swallow does not make a summer
sweet to view the sea when standing on
the shore
[Music]
unripe grapes get sweet as honey but at
a slow pace
[Music]
too many opinions sink the boat
it is difficult to argue with the belly
because it has no ears
[Music]
the excess of a virtue is of ice
it is not what they profess but what
they practice that makes them good
you can't hide behind your finger
you can tell who the good semen are
during a storm
[Music]
the sins we often regret are the sins we
never commit
a drop of wisdom is better than a sea of
gold
[Music]
I'll receive advice only the wise profit
from it
the donkey called the rooster big-headed
the camel can't see her own hump
one thing I know that I know nothing
this is the source of my wisdom
foreign
wise men speak because they have
something to say fools speak because
they have to say something
[Music]
you will never do anything in this world
without courage it is the greatest
quality of the Mind next to honor
[Music]
let food be thy medicine and Medicine
thy food
life is short art endures
[Music]
one of the penalties for refusing to
participate in politics is that you end
up being governed by your inferiors
nature does nothing without a purpose
[Music]
wit is educated insolence
the roots of Education are bitter but
the fruit is sweet
The Art of Living Well and the Art of
dying well are one
Only The Dead have seen the end of War
[Music]
in all things of nature there is
something of the marvelous
[Music]
ten soldiers wisely LED will beat a
hundred without a head
give me a lever long enough and a
fulcrum on which to place it and I shall
move the world
education is an ornament in prosperity
and a refuge in adversity
[Music]
the greater the difficulty the more the
glory and surmounting it
[Music]
Love Is All We Have the only way that
each can help the other
[Music]
success is dependent upon effort
whoever does not want to need sifts for
10 days
[Music]
eyes that don't see each other
frequently are soon forgotten
[Music]
the devil has many legs
when you hear about many cherries bring
a small basket
whoever is in a hurry stumbles
[Music]
a rose comes out of a thorn and a thorn
comes out of a rose
how you make your bed is how you are
going to sleep
well-being is attained little by little
but it is no little thing itself
[Music]
the deaf man's door knock as much as you
like
that we'll find rest from vain fancies
if thou doest Every Act in life as
though it were thy last
[Music]
the drowning man grasps his own hair
small opportunities are often the
beginning of great Enterprises
an orator without judgment is a horse
without a bridle
a lucky person is someone who plants
Pebbles and harvests potatoes
the art of being a slave is to rule
one's master
as a matter of self-preservation a man
needs good friends or Ardent enemies for
the former instruct him and the latter
take him to task
he who cannot bear Misfortune is truly
unfortunate
a miser and a liar bargain quickly
[Music]
the unexamined life is not worth living
either dance well or quit the ballroom
leave your sons well instructed rather
than Rich the hopes of the instructed
are better than the wealth of the
ignorant
thank you
those who aim at Great Deeds must also
suffer greatly
in order to please others we lose our
hold on our life's purpose
[Music]
written laws are like spiders webs they
catch the weak and poor but are torn in
pieces by the rich and Powerful
[Music]
he who becomes a sheep is eaten by a
wolf
reserve your right to think for even to
think wrongly is better than not to
think at all
the wildest Cults make the best horses
a true enemy is better than a false
friend
whatever is good to know is difficult to
learn
[Music]
quality is not an act it is a habit
love is composed of a single soul
inhabiting two bodies
[Music]
is the mark of an educated mind to be
able to entertain a thought without
accepting it
[Music]
there is no great genius without some
touch of Madness
whoever is delighted in solitude is
either a wild beast or a god
[Music]
pleasure in the job puts perfection in
the work
[Music]
depends upon ourselves
the worst form of inequality is to try
to make unequal things equal
the aim of the wise is not to secure
pleasure but to avoid pain
[Music]
good habits formed at youth make all the
difference
the energy of the mind is the essence of
life
[Music]
personal beauty is a greater
recommendation than any letter of
reference
[Music]
youth is easily deceived because it is
quick to Hope
moral Excellence comes about as a result
of habit
we become just by doing just acts
temperate by doing temperate acts Brave
by doing Brave Acts
dignity does not consist in possessing
honors but in deserving them
wishing to be friends is quick work but
friendship is a slow ripening fruit
those who educate children well are more
to be honored than those who produce
them for the latter only gave them life
the former The Art of Living Well
all paid jobs absorb and degrade the
mind
he who is to be a good ruler must have
first been ruled
[Music]
create Gods after their own image not
only with regard to their form but with
regard to their mode of life
the least initial deviation from the
truth is later multiplied a thousand
fold
[Music]
most people would rather give than get
affection
[Music]
do not spoil what you have by Desiring
what you have not remember that what you
now have was once among the things you
only hope for
[Music]
it is not so much our friends help that
helps us as the confidence of their help
we must exercise ourselves in the things
which bring happiness since if that be
present we have everything
and if that be absent all our actions
are directed toward attaining it
he who has Peace of Mind disturbs
neither himself nor another
Justice is a compact not to harm or be
harmed
[Music]
the natural healing Force within each of
us is the greatest force in getting well
[Music]
leave your drugs in the chemist pot if
you can heal the patient with food
sleep and watchfulness both of them when
a moderate constitute disease
to do nothing is sometimes a good remedy
each of the substances of a man's diet
acts upon his body and changes it in
some way upon these changes his whole
life depends
wine is an appropriate thing for mankind
both for the healthy body and for the
ailing man
walking is man's best medicine
[Music]
what medicines do not heal the Lance
will
what the Lance does not heal fire will
the soul is the same in all living
creatures although the body of each is
different
[Music]
mathematics reveals its Secrets only to
those who approach it with pure love for
its own Beauty
[Music]
he who knows how to speak knows also
when
game in life
tranquility and rationality are the
cornerstones of happiness
to be rich is not the end but only a
change of worries
being happy is knowing how to be content
with little
nothing is enough for the man to whom
enough is too little
foreign
live your life without attracting
attention
pay attention to your enemies for they
are the first to discover your mistakes
mothers are fonder than fathers of their
children because they are more certain
they are their own
character may also be called the most
effective means of persuasion
[Music]
personal beauty is a greater
recommendation than any letter of
reference
[Music]
he who hath many friends hath none
the greater the difficulty the more the
glory and surmounting it
do everything as if someone were looking
at you
[Music]
he who needs riches least enjoys riches
most
[Music]
the wealth required by nature is limited
and is easy to procure but the wealth
required by vain ideals extends to
Infinity
[Music]